I have a problem.
I like to experiment and play with infrastructure
as code tools.
And in fact, I don't just use code
for infrastructure. I use code for everything.
Setting up my personal email addresses,
configure DNS records, deploying Kubernetes clusters,
you name it. As you may be aware,
I used to work for a company called
Pulumi. They're one of the leaders in the
infrastructure's code tool, but not the leader. So
since I've left Pulumi,
I've been wanting to make sure that I
keep up my skills with these other tools,
notably Terraform,
Terraform CDK,
CDKs,
and Crossplane.
However,
when you start to use more than one
infrastructure as code tool, you have a problem.
As you start to use a micro stack
pattern,
using Pulumi c to spin up a Kubernetes
cluster, Terraform to manage DNS records, CDK to
deploy to the Kubernetes cluster and so on.
You have this explicit set of dependencies,
which are quite hard to make explicit inside
of a code pipeline.
These can typically be in different repositories
and chaining repository actions together is already very
tedious. So there has to be something out
there to help make our lives easier.
Right?
Exactly.
Today, we're gonna take a look at Env0.
Let's dive in. First up, what is Env0?
Well,
it is a tool for infrastructure as code,
but not an infrastructure as code tool.
What do I mean? Well, you can't use
Env0 to provision
cloud infrastructure,
but you can use an infrastructure as code
tool like Pulumi and Terraform and CDK
and have m zero act as an orchestration
or workflow layer.
M zero can even manage your Terraform state
if you need somewhere to keep it safe.
So we're gonna take a look at a
demo today
where I've got like a real world example
of me personally wanting to spin up a
Kubernetes cluster and for today I'll use Civo
Cloud and I'm going to do it with
Pulumi. But I also have another stack,
an application
that maybe wants to deploy something to this
cluster.
But step one is actually to connect
a IP address
with the DNS record
because my applications aren't that good if I
can't route traffic to them publicly.
So let's dive into the code and take
a look at how m zero works. So
let's take a look at the Pulumi stack
first.
This is a very simple Pulumi program.
We import the Civo package.
We create a firewall.
We create a cluster.
I'm reserving an IP address so that I
can use an annotation
on
the ingress controller and tell it to use
this IP address within the cluster.
Lastly, I export the load balancer IP and
the kube config
just in case I want to use these
in another stack.
Now this is a very traditional
Pulumi program. In fact,
there's no concept of n zero here at
all
except for the Env0.
Yaml.
Now, we just need a little bit of
information here that tells Env0 how to get
ready to run this Pulumi stack.
It already knows how to do a Pulumi
up. It already knows how to do a
Pulumi preview and it already knows how to
do Pulumi destroy.
What it doesn't know is whether your Pulumi
program is JavaScript or TypeScript or Node. Js,
Python,
Java,
Go,
etcetera.
So what we're actually doing in the m
zero dot yaml is providing some steps for
deploy and destroy.
And all we're saying is that after we
set up any variables, run an NPM install
because we need all of the NPM, all
the node packages to be available for Pulumi
to run successfully.
And this is just a simple debug command,
but before we run a Pulumi login, it
may be useful to having your logs the
Pulumi version.
So let's do that.
We also repeat the same steps for destroy.
Next,
we have a Terraform program and
there is nothing m zero about this directory.
You'll see here that I have a civil
token and a Cloudflare token.
We then specify the Terraform provider block and
we say that we require civil and Cloudflare.
We then configure our civil and Cloudflare providers
and then using two data lookups.
One, I'm looking up the Cloudflare zone for
the Rawkode Academy domain.
Next, I'm doing a lookup against Civo Cloud
to grab the load balancer IP address.
Lastly,
I create a Cloudflare record.
If you've used Terraform before,
none of this is particularly new.
And we don't need any m zero yaml
here because Terraform is Terraform.
It's HCL based. We don't need node modules.
We don't need Python modules, etcetera. When we
have dependent stacks like this, we need to
be able to define a workflow that says,
well, we need the platform to exist first
before we do anything else. And this case,
we want to spin up this evil cloud
Kubernetes instance, and then
hook up the DNS record. Why? Because there's
a dependency.
The DNS record needs the IP address of
the load balancer before it can begin.
So you'll notice in the top level of
this repository,
we have an m0.
Workflow. Yaml.
And all we're specifying here is a list
of environments and any dependencies that we have.
It's a small bit of glue, but it
does powerful, powerful things.
First one, we define the platform is called
platform with a template of platform.
Don't worry if you don't know what the
template is. We're gonna take a look at
that through the m zero UI in just
a moment.
Next, we have an environment called DNS,
which has a name of DNS, a template
of DNS
and it needs the platform to run first.
This is how we encode our dependency and
guarantee the running order of these two stacks.
Not only that, when we do a destroy,
it'll run them in reverse making sure all
the dependent stacks are destroyed first before any
of the base layers.
Pretty neat. Right?
So let's pop over to the m zero
UI
and get this up and running. Here we
have the m zero UI and I've created
a project called
level up.
If you click on level up, we'll see
that we have no environments.
Just a moment ago, we took a look
at the m0.workflow.yaml
which listed the environments.
We have or we want a platform environment
and a DNS environment.
And those had something called templates.
So let's go to organization
templates,
where I've already configured our platform and DNS.
But let's click on settings and see what
they look like.
First, a template we have to tell it
which infrastructure as code tool we are using.
You'll see here I've selected Pulumi.
However, I could have picked Kubernetes,
CloudFormation,
a workflow, Terraform, or Terraform.
But let's go back to Pulumi.
We got the template a name here and
calling it platform just because that's what I
have in my m0.yaml.
Feel free to provide a description if you
want.
You then get to select the version of
Pulumi that you wish to use. I am
going to use latest.
You get to define reshi logic on failure,
whether to do it on deploy, destroy or
both.
And if you need an SSH key to
access any of your code because they're in
private repositories,
you can configure that as so.
Next, we click on VCS.
Here, we have to point it to the
repository.
For today's example, I'm using gitlab.com
and I've already authorized myself as a user.
From here, we can type in the name
of our repository.
For this, it's Rawkode Academy DevOps tutorials m
zero.
We choose the branch that we want it
to run against. Main is a pretty stable
choice.
And then if
the code, the infrastructure is code that you
want to run as this template lives and
a sub directory like mines and the Pulumi
directory,
you could that here.
Next, we specify the variables.
So I know that I want to store
my state using Pulumi cloud. So I need
a Pulumi access token key.
And you can paste in your own value
there.
My Pulumi code also speaks to the Civo
API.
Now, I could use Pulumi secrets, but instead
I've opted to use Pulumi token as part
of the environment variables where I've also saved
an API token.
Lastly, we tell it the projects are allowed
to consume this template.
I don't need to save this because nothing
has changed.
For DNS, we'll open it up. You'll see
it's configured as a Terraform template.
The name is DNS and just like Pulumi,
I get the version, the retry logic and
any SSH key.
This is pointed to the same repository,
the m zero DevOps tutorial repository
on the same branch,
but the directory the code lives in is
different.
In this case, it's Terraform.
On variables,
almost the exact same thing.
However,
I was able to use this wonderful load
variables from code button and we'll take a
look at that in just a moment.
But m zero has really good knowledge and
understanding of Terraform programs.
If you add a new variable block to
the code, you can tell emcee to scan
it and make it available on the UI.
And lastly,
we've set the project to level up two.
So let's pop back to our project environments.
Here I'm gonna say create new environment.
Now we have a choice of just using
our two templates, but then there wouldn't be
any dependencies mapping between the two.
So instead I'm going to say use a
version control system.
And this time I'm not specifically configuring Terraform
or Pulumi, but instead a workflow.
It's in the same repository
with the same user,
m0
like so.
I want to use the same branch, only
this time the m zero workflow file is
in the top level directory.
We can indicate that with a dot.
I click next. We don't need any variables
and we can give this any environment name
that we want.
I'm going to call this production.
You can provide a workflow workspace name if
you want, however, is not mandatory.
We have a default checkbox on which will
say redeploy
every time we push to get.
M zero actually has really good integration with
GitHub and GitLab and that when you open
a pull or merge request, you will get
a comment with the plan results.
We'll see that in a moment too.
If you want to enable drift detection, this
takes a cron syntax
like so.
However, the minimum time or the minimum drift
interval is one hour.
So we'll say to run at five past
every hour
and click done.
As part of this new environment, this new
workflow,
a run for both of our templates will
now begin.
So,
we'll come back in just a moment when
it's completed. Okay.
The workflow run is finished.
We scroll down. We'll see that the platform
has a tick and the DNS has a
tick. This means that both runs completed successfully.
Looking at the platform, we can see the
clone,
loads the MZ file,
does some preview and stuff.
And eventually, we have the longest part of
the run, the Pulumi up at three minutes.
We can expand that and see all of
the Pulumi output
as well as the resources,
as well as the explicit outputs we defined
in code.
So, let's make a change to this repository.
First, we want to see the variable scan.
So we're gonna add a new variable to
the Terraform and we'll call this
name. Not very original, but it'll it'll do.
Let's also add a comment to our DNS
record.
And we'll just say hello
and zero.
And let's make a small modification to the
Pulumi program
and we're just gonna request an extra IP
address
and we'll call this platform
app.
So let's be a good citizen within our
organization
and create a branch.
New
million
dollar
idea.
We can do a git add.
Be the worst developer in the world and
commit changes.
And we'll do a git push. So let's
pop over to GitLab and open the merge
request.
And create.
If we click on changes, we'll see the
two modifications that we made or three modifications
that we made to our program.
And if we pop over to pipelines,
we haven't configured any CICD for this. There
is no dot GitLab YAML workflow file.
This is m zero speaking to GitLab
as a GitLab application.
And if we click
on our pipeline,
we'll see that m zero is running a
plan
for our production environment.
So let's click on it.
And we'll see that it's already succeeded.
And if we look at the Pulumi preview,
we'll see that we have one resource to
create.
So let's go back to our merge request.
And if we scroll down,
we have comments.
One,
we can see that Pulumi wants to add
one resource and four are unchanged.
And if we expand Oh,
someone forgot to set a default value. So
let's do that now.
Let's pop open our Terraform.
Set default,
David,
add,
commit
and push.
So let's open the merge request.
We click the button
and we say create.
And what's happening,
mZero has a GitLab application,
which has injected a pipeline for us. We
have not created a GitLab workflow file.
This is all handled for you by using
mZero.
If we click on the pipeline,
we'll see that it's running our DNS and
platform jobs as part of our production environment.
You can click on this and it will
take you to m zero.
And here we can see that this plan
was a success. If we scroll down, we'll
see that the Terraform plan
wants to update the Cloudflare record with the
comment that we added.
So let's browse back to our merge request.
And if we scroll down,
we'll see that we don't have to comment
yet.
So let's just give that another second.
There we have it. Now we have our
comments. The Pulumi plan has succeeded and it
wants to create one more resource, which is,
of course, our new reserved IP.
Down here for the Terraform job, we see
that one resource needs to change.
So, I'm not gonna wait. I'm just going
to merge this immediately.
And done.
So let's head back to M 0.
And you'll see that our production environment already
has a deploy in progress.
Now that our merge request has been merged,
it's going to run the Pulumi up and
the Terraform apply.
Let's just give that a moment.
Well,
Let's head back over
to our project templates
and click on settings for DNS.
Let's go to variables
and you'll see that we still have our
Civo token and our Cloudflare token,
but we did add that extra variable to
our Terraform code.
So let's click load variables
from code.
I love that feature.
It has scanned our HCL detected that we
have key of name with a default value
David,
which we can override
like so
and hit save.
So as we've seen so far,
we can take multiple
infrastructure
as code tools,
repositories,
or subdirectories,
build workflows with explicit dependencies.
This part's great for the options that we've
already seen on the m zero UI.
Terraform,
Terraform, Pulumi,
CloudFormation.
But what about CDKTF?
I'm a big fan of Terraform CDK.
So let's see an action as part of
m zero's workflow.
First,
we'll create a directory called CDKTF,
where we'll run CDKTF
in it.
Let's go with TypeScript,
and the name and description is just fine.
Now we're not going to use Terraform Cloud
because m zero is actually managing all of
our state files in the background.
We didn't actually specify any state storage for
the previous Terraform program and nor do you
need to.
Now for this example, I'm gonna keep it
relatively contrived and we're going to use the
random provider.
Let's go back to our code.
We have our new directory,
a main dot ts,
and we have
an empty stack.
Now, we don't actually have to add anything
to the stack in order to show it
working with m zero.
We can actually just go to the CLI
and ensure that CDKTF
synth runs,
which it does.
Now the way that CDKTF works is you
write your code in TypeScript, you run a
synth, and it generates HCL
for a normal standard Terraform run.
So let's configure m zero to do this
too.
Let's go to our code and we'll create
an m zero
dot yaml.
We'll go to the Pulumi one
and copy it to make this a little
bit faster.
We'll delete destroy for now
and just focus on
deploy setup variables after.
Here we're doing our NPM install.
What we can also do an NPM install
global
CDKTF
CLI.
Now because this is a global install, it
will require
sudo.
From here, you can actually just run CDKTF
since.
However, we want to copy all of the
generated code and to the current directory.
We just need to put the stack name
in here. If you're unsure, run the CDKTF
locally,
the CDKTF synth,
because you can just expand the dot out
directory, the stack, you'll see the stack name
and then we have our JSON.
And we want to grab that to the
current working directory.
And we'll want to copy this
for destroy,
Like so. So let's modify
our workflow file.
Now we can add CDKTF,
name CDKTF,
template name CDKTF.
And we'll see that this needs
platform
and DNS.
In fact, let's remove the DNS
and we'll see that m zero will run
these stacks in parallel, which is also kind
of cool. So, let's commit this
and push.
So if we come back to our project,
we will have
our production environment.
Now it's inactive and passed, but if we
click on deployments, we'll see that our last
run failed.
And it's failing because we do not have
the template CDKTF.
Let's go to organization templates
and create new.
Now because we want us to run the
Terraform eventually,
we just select Terraform.
We call this CDKTF
to match what we put in a workflow
YAML.
And click next
and configure
a repository
one last time.
And the directory for this is CDKTF.
Now we don't need any variables, so we
don't need to parse anything here. So let's
just click next
and done.
Awesome.
Let's go back to our project environment.
Click
and we'll see this field run here.
Let's kick off a new one.
Main branch
and run.
Fingers crossed.
And now we can see from the graph
that the platform is running and that our
DNS and CDK Terraform
are dependents.
So let's give that a few moments to
finish.
Ta da.
Now we have m zero workflows
handling dependencies and workflows for Pulumi,
Terraform, and Terraform CDK.
Sweet.
So m zero is a really cool tool.
As you explore infrastructure as code,
mZero gives you a few key benefits.
One, it understands Terraform pretty damn well.
You don't have to worry about your state
file anymore. Let mZero worry about it for
you.
It can also scan and pull out variables
and bring them into a UI for you
to configure.
It gives you a nice graph of all
the resources that are being created,
integrates through your source control system for pull
request updates and plans,
and handles all the workflows and dependencies across
these tools.
I can't state that enough.
As you adopt infrastructure as code tools, these
dependencies are always very implicit.
We always have the big bang problem.
What if I wanna spin up a new
environment from scratch?
Well, it's not a single Pulumi run. It's
not a single Terraform run.
It's actually many of the above.
The m zero brings a way for us
to codify that too,
which is pretty neat.
Go check out m zero at the links
in the description below and on the screen
now.
The code is available at gitlab.com/RawkodeAcademy,
where by the time you watch this, I'll
have cleaned up the commit history.
Promise.
So go have some fun. We'll catch you
all next time.